[Music]
it's this week we've got drunken luggage
candy cocaine and song requests standoff
I love candy cocaine's mm-hmm this is a
rapper named candy cocaine yeah it's a
proper story there was this man that had
one piece of luggage that he checked in
and that was a can of beer he checked in
a can of beer Wow
and the airline let him did they put a
fragile on there and over no it's just
like that why did he check in a can of
beer so he said that I haven't his
friend they were just laughing about it
I thought it would be like a funny joke
or whatever so then bored out of their
[ __ ] mind I was god damn it hey
Cletus you know we'll be hilarious this
kind of beer was a domestic flight in
Australia it was from Melbourne - oh
it's not Cletus it's not Cletus I bet
it's like some bullion stuff bogan it's
their version of redneck they were
playing Qantas and Qantas they love
Qantas yeah they don't charge to check
in your bag so they were like try
checking in a Canterbury it was the very
first item how cute that's crazy that it
survived though so yeah they were saying
that like it was perfect like the can
wasn't damaged at all it wasn't they
should have opened it the minute that's
better than the US Post Office it's
probably a shake and that [ __ ] can
was damaged I would file a claim
medially pissed I call the scene but
they handled it with care cuz it's
either standing upright or like let's
make sure that this is really safe roll
it down slowly somebody catch it at the
bottom Australians love beer so they're
gonna cherish that thing I don't even
recognize what kind of beer that was
yeah I don't know that's not phosphorus
export export yeah that's dope everyone
had a sense of humor though yes I think
here they'd be like you can't do that
nope you're not doing it
they're such jerks yeah I had a really
nice experience with the TSA so I had my
knife in my backpack and I totally
forgot about it and I went through the
x-ray and then they're like I have to
check your bag and then they pulled out
the knife and I was like oh god that was
in there and he's like you want to check
it in and I'm all like [ __ ] I don't have
time cuz I only had like five minutes to
get to my [ __ ] and all night two hours
before I just my favorite knife too and
I'm like ahhh
and then he's like whoa I could just do
it real quick we could just go
downstairs and like check it in your bag
and I'm like I'm not checking in any
bags he's like oh we could check in your
backpack and I was like tank dude you
really want me to keep my knife don't
you that's dope
yeah and I was like it's cool man just
throw it away and I walked away and I
was like [ __ ] man I can't say it was a
[ __ ] I had a bottle of lotion and that
[ __ ] would not let me keep it she was
like well sir you can't bring this in
it's over the outside was not the
container is I should go see the bottle
is already two thirds gone so they're
liquid quantity it's not yeah so she's
like no sir but it says that's like
that's like this exactly 16 ounce or
something sighs we don't we don't allow
that exactly and I just looked at the
lady and I was like are you serious she
goes yes sir you have to follow
instructions I was like cool and then
she I took the thing and I looked at her
face I went are you happy right and she
goes thank you very much as like ah
she'd even take the insults off like
every TSA agent there they give
themselves their own credentials to be
authorities yeah so like I was trying to
go through TSA with Joel one time and
then the guy was like oh your gel is
over three ounces or whatever and I'm
like no it's not and then and then he
was like how do you know not because I
bought it in the Travel section so in
the Travel section they make it where
you're gonna be able to travel and he
goes well I was in the Navy and I'm like
I don't know what that has to
yeah he was like oh I'm in the Navy cool
I was in the Marines I'm like so what
you're good at estimating how many flew
it out I didn't know that was a Navy
trait yeah I didn't know that's one of
the skills you picked up like well i'm
5-8 i'm like he didn't follow it up with
anything he just said well i'm he's I'm
in the Navy I think what happened was
like he realized how dumb he was and he
just had to pull something out yeah that
was his peak of his life he just grabbed
that he goes but you said this is like
they're two ounces I'm the baby
[Laughter]
Sagittarius yeah speak about it you
broke him are you broken cuz he with all
that stuff you like the liquid bottle
stuff usually like when they see it
almost that was the only time that ever
happened they go okay cool and they just
put it in it's not a big [ __ ] deal
man it's lotion it's the size of the
bottle
yeah it's clear I pissed me off dude I
was all ashy in Colorado [ __ ]
ridiculous
you didn't do a spit-take me oh it makes
it worse it's what my mom used to do
she'll but all your face is ashy it
makes it work oh she did not that's what
animals do animals liquor young but not
cuz it's a she doesn't smell and they
did to clean because it's a she
[Laughter]
what was your probably called colder in
the winter oh my face gets pretty oily
most as I'm I don't have to like wipe it
down is it right now like unnecessary I
like the way actually feels now but II
feel maybe that's why I got traumatized
I don't like putting lotion on my face
cuz your mom selects feels like [ __ ]
spit
yeah would never you know like moms
usually like oh I would never do no I
would always get Isaac's own hand make
him lick his own finger and then I'll
use
I'm like I'm not trying to put my salon
that's weird I mean it's just like I'm
gonna do the shopping do that same [ __ ]
can do your own salon my friend's mom
said that when he was a baby and he had
little boogers in his nose she would
suck the [ __ ] out of his mouth and
spit it up oh so so she's a little beige
almost he has a little [ __ ] boogers
and she'll like the [ __ ] boogers out
of her nose never what ethnicity Chinese
of course
oh that sounds nasty but it sounds kind
of tight too I like how you're
celebrating over there you married a
Chinese man they're not the ultimate
lost ever I think it keeps validating
all this [ __ ] that I always say and I'm
like of course your face Chinese people
who you married to this [ __ ] right
but this is better better than the
squeeze ball what it's more natural than
the squeeze ball sure ah what see you I
don't mind
you have a kid don't bring that up he's
just the pea would you rather have a kid
that has a nose full of boogers
no there's a [ __ ] concerns ball and I
but you what if you freaking suck their
sinuses out because it's so strong it's
not that strong or you can control it
with your mouth your parents did it with
you you guys survived I'm sure our child
will survive my mom plays suck my nose
too yeah so now for our next story have
you guys heard of Coco Loco yeah let's
go Coco it's in Peru they have this
crazy cocaine what prove that this crazy
cocaine party and everyone goes [ __ ]
done this is just a voiceover yeah but
his baby especially the Morgan Freeman's
voice oh so it's a product that looks
like this and people are snorting it
well it's a product meant for snorting
so it's like
it's chocolate so it's not absurd but
they're starting it are saying like you
know you shouldn't snort anything
because your lungs aren't meant to be
filters there's only yeah that's [ __ ]
dumb that's like coming out with the
drink and you're supposed to snort the
drink yeah we got this new dream or
there's this product made for something
else but everyone's using it wrong
that's original the creator of this
product created it to snort you know
what they should really call it as coco
is coco moko local you know why cuz if
you snorting it you're eating the
[ __ ] boogers - can you can you eat it
yeah can you just put that in milk and
make chocolate milk like a normal person
that's a good question I sort this the
milk I'm not sure if you can't what I
don't see why not though because it is
chocolate chocolate powder like what the
[ __ ] and how much cocaine is in it he's
29 years old he created this company
called legal lien and so would you the
way he describes his products is saying
that you get this minor euphoric rush a
calm energy and focus he feel mint
motivated to want to go out sounds like
God has asked me a lot as a kid
yeah yo you for rush bread yeah you're
saying it's a stimulant
and a stress reducer so in that in the
container it's ten servings for 25 bucks
and he was initially inspired by YouTube
videos of people out in Europe snorting
chocolate so then that's when he got the
idea to create this product we just
copied an idea the Chinese guy I don't
know Nick Chen Anderson so there's
absolutely no proof that any of that
[ __ ] works he just saw it on YouTube and
thought it was a good idea it's a
stimulant and a stress reliever bro
because you know what else is a
stimulant stressful either masturbation
oh yeah I get stimulated and then it
gets relieved
exactly you know we free it's as natural
as it gets getting a [ __ ] there you
go here's where people that are trying
to get like that boost of energy like
you know what else will do that for you
punch in the face maybe maybe if you
don't knock him out I want a boost of
energy
let me snort some chocolate fake cocaine
I don't know how that commercials gonna
work out I do want to try I do want to
see I just want to try it yeah well I I
got I got a bunch of bananas and I'm
thinking I could sprinkle that
[ __ ] on a banana and eat it
chocolate banana there's absolutely no
way you snorting [ __ ] sugar up your
nose is good for your sinus cavity I'm
just gonna get infected it's gonna hurt
it's all bad dude I don't like using
beings that is not what it's meant for
because to me that's like putting
headphones in my mouth and trying to
listen to music you know what they just
need to mix this [ __ ] with or watch a
movie Special K or coke because I
remember when I used to do special case
[ __ ] I would snort that [ __ ] and I would
feel these drips coming down the back of
my throat and I'm like oh I don't wanna
[ __ ] well I don't want to spit
because I don't want to waste the drug I
paid so much for but at the same time
I'm swallowing it like that's all nasty
man they need to [ __ ] make this
different it's so gross
maybe you can combine it with Coco Loco
so yeah that's a good idea
real question why why do people snort
cocaine like is there another way to do
cocaine as opposed to snort no wonder it
goes like yeah well I mean they could
turn it into crack and smoke it I think
they snort it because the membranes in
your nasal cavity is really thin so it
can absorb it very quickly versus if you
were to put it in like water and then
digest it and drink it you could come it
- it takes longer yeah like you know
when your people are they put it like
here yeah you could literally see your
blood vessel you could also finger bang
your [ __ ] with it people do that to
you that's hardcore
you know my nose is so sensitive people
do put it up their ass I never did
cocaine only smoked crack there's a
difference balus from Cannes
that's ketamine get it right that's
nothing else okay that is animal
tranquilizer that my friends got it you
wanna
I don't know but I know how to cook that
[ __ ] cuz it came in a vial where you
know what like those vial with a rubber
at the top you supposed to put a syringe
in I will cap that open put it on a
plate bola pot of water put that [ __ ] on
top when it's all evaporated I scrape it
out and me and my friends would scrape
it out in my living room but that's I
don't condone drug use I just picture
you like at a church pew like condemning
everybody you [ __ ] drug addicts
that's bad by the way I was like 15 and
I was like long time ago in another life
mm-hmm how did you learn to do that when
you were 15 for our last story that was
this man in Massachusetts near Boston
that drove up to a radio station and was
demanding the radio station to play an
Insane Clown Posse song a lot to say
about this nuts song is there strong
feelings it's called my axe and he
showed up with an axe oh oh [ __ ] he was
threatening them yeah any chef with
knives and it led to a three-hour
standoff pretty much with the cops I
don't I will actually I don't even know
that people still listen to them dude
they still got Juggalos around man
where somewhere Juggalos Ohio and
Indiana man Clown Posse okay I can't
believe we're still talking about their
fans
aka Juggalos they always make the news I
see how you know the FBI even classified
them back in 2011 as a game what could
they lose they do a lot of they're just
like clowns I'm a gigolo spending lots
of dough and stuff like this guy yeah
apparently he's a Juggalo cuz he was
demanding that that song he's not in his
Juggalo outfit yeah what
face mask yeah you're gonna go go
hundred percent yeah what's up with bad
dude he just woke up that morning and
he's like I gotta hear this [ __ ] song
didn't have a cellphone yeah he was
huffing stuff out of a paper bag to it
so for sure he was on drugs he was on
that paint he was doing he's like yeah
he went up to the building he told the
secretary he wanted that song to be
played she was like we can't play that
he went out went to his car starting the
axe and like just threatening people and
then that's when the cops arrived and
they locks him in what establishment is
it's a radio station oh he got into a
radios all you wanted it to play yeah
well my mind went somewhere else why the
[ __ ] didn't even get in with the axe for
some reason I thought he was at a
fast-food restaurant and then he was
demanding that the fast-food people play
oh that's funny that's what I was
thinking right now and I don't know why
my mind went there you hungry you're
hungry
what establishment of one that was in
the McDonald's a KFC which what was it
you got that kind of axe yeah what were
you expecting I would handle one I was
thinking like those medieval big ones
like a battle axe I was thinking a pop
onion one they finally got them they
even taped them looks like Robin Thicke
or something yeah it was all over this
song and then the cops were even
considering like they were trying to
figure out a way to play that song to
calm them down cuz it was three hours
can we can we play it just for him
can we play that song I'll pull it up I
want to know that this song must be
really good if it's like that's my [ __ ]
man either heard it in like a long time
did he have Spotify or something gonna
have this to himself I wonder if it's on
Spotify maybe it's so like it had to be
on YouTube or something does he not know
how to use a computer maybe maybe it was
a heat-of-the-moment thing he's in the
car he didn't have a cell phone so he
decided to drive straight to a radio
station and then the radio wasn't
playing his song he was looking so he
wanted the radio to play it how did he
find the radio station without his cell
phone maybe it's a small town and
everyone knows where the local radio
station is
true here's ready for the song yeah
let's listen to it for the Juggalos just
want to put a clown makeup on now
[Music]
what does he mean my ex will give you a
forehead of what I don't know me and my
ex but that but that won't it sounds
like the soundtrack of a nightmare huh
maybe that's their style is like hey
we're scary you can only be our fan if
you're scary as well yeah so let's all
be scary together I hope you guys
enjoyed this video for more please
subscribe to our channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]